Amigos, amigas de VisualPolitik, tengo que
anunciaros algo muy importante. Donald Trump…
¡Ha vuelto!
Sí, habéis oído bien. Trump ha vuelto a
dar de qué hablar. Y diréis ¿Por qué?
Pues por esto.
Trump denuncia a Twitter, Google y Facebook
alegando “censura”
BBC 07-07-2021
Como sabéis, tras el asalto al Capitolio,
todas las grandes plataformas de Internet
eliminaron todas las cuentas de Donald Trump
¿Por qué? Pues porque Trump estuvo agitando
a sus seguidores horas antes de que tomaran
el Capitolio. Es decir, no le acusan de haber
organizado el asalto. Pero sí le culpan por
haber creado el clima de odio que provocó
el ataque.
Y esto abre un debate muy serio ¿Hasta qué
punto estamos hablando de censura? Y ya sé
lo que estaréis pensando muchos ¡Son empresas
privadas! Tanto Facebook, como Twitter o YouTube
pueden tener las normas que quieran. Y sí,
tenéis razón ¿El problema? El problema
es que estas tres plataformas tienen el oligopolio
del contenido online. Es decir, que si YouTube
cierra un canal… es muy difícil, casi imposible,
que ese canal encuentre otra plataforma parecida
desde donde emitir por internet.
¡Pero esperad un momento! Porque no hablamos
sólo de un capricho de las grandes tecnológicas.
En realidad, tanto Twitter como Facebook como
Google están entre la espada y la pared.
Por un lado, Trump y muchos otros les denuncian
por violar la libertad de expresión. Pero,
por otro lado, muchos gobiernos les presionan
para que eliminen todo lo que se considera
(((HACER GESTO DE COMILLAS CON LOS DEDOS)))
“contenido nocivo”. Atentos.
Facebook y YouTube encaran nuevas y estrictas
leyes sobre vídeos explícitos o extremistas
Europa propone nuevas reglas y multas para
forzar a las redes sociales a moderar los
vídeos online
The Guardian 24-05-2017
Para que os hagáis una idea, algunas de estas
leyes contemplan multas de hasta 50 millones
de euros. La pregunta es ¿De verdad hablamos
de censura? ¿Hasta qué punto es razonable
exigir que YouTube nos proteja del “contenido
nocivo”? Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas
pero antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
¿CUÁNTA LIBERTAD DE EXPRESIÓN ES DEMASIADA?
En noviembre de 2015, una chica española
fue detenida en el Aeropuerto de Barajas,
en Madrid, cuando estaba a punto de viajar
a Turquía para unirse al DAESH. Lo más increíble
de esta historia es que la chica en cuestión
ni siquiera había nacido en una familia musulmana.
Esta chica se radicalizó viendo propaganda
del DAESH en redes sociales. Hubo un tiempo,
hace no tantos años, en el que era absurdamente
fácil encontrar vídeos de propaganda islamista
radical. Estaban en el mismo Instagram. Por
supuesto que, en casi todos los países democráticos
hay leyes que prohíben la propaganda terrorista.
Es decir, aunque la Constitución de cualquier
país Europeo reconozca la libertad de expresión,
hay algunos límites: la llamada explícita
a la violencia es uno de ellos.
¿El problema? Que, por muchas leyes que haya,
es muy difícil impedir que alguien cree un
vídeo de propaganda terrorista y se haga
viral. Es la otra cara de la libertad que
nos da Internet. Por aquellos años, sólo
UNA plataforma tenía los algoritmos para
detectar los vídeos del DAESH a tiempo. Y
sí, esa plataforma era YouTube ¿Por qué?
Eso es tema para otro vídeo. Pero lo cierto
es que, tanto Facebook, como Instagram, como
Twitter no se habían preocupado por evitar
que los grupos extremos como el Daesh o tantos
otros camparan a sus anchas. Y así es como
saltaron las alarmas en muchos gobiernos.
Pensadlo bien: por mucho que la policía persiguiera
a los terroristas, cada día surgían nuevos
adeptos al Daesh que se había radicalizado
por Internet. Y así es como varios países
en Europa sacaron sus propias leyes para responsabilizar
a Facebook y Twitter del contenido que tenían:
el primero y el más importante fue… ¡Alemania!
Pensadlo bien: desde los años 50, Alemania
tiene leyes muy estrictas para evitar discursos
neonazis. Negar el Holocausto puede llegar
a castigarse con años de cárcel. Y, en algunos
casos, estas leyes han llegado a situaciones
tan absurdas como esta.
Wolfenstein retirado de la venta en Alemania
debido a los símbolos nazis
Gamasutra 22-09-2009
(Por cierto, que desde el año 2019, Alemania
ha suavizado estas leyes y ahora, por fin,
el Wolfenstein vuelve a ser legal en Alemania)
Lo cierto es que Alemania siempre ha tenido
bastantes restricciones para evitar los discursos
extremistas. Así que, en el año 2017, decidieron
ser pioneros en una restricción más. Sí,
amigos de VisualPolitik, hablamos de la llamada
ley NETZDG. (si, así es como todo el mundo
conoce esta ley). Según esta ley, tanto YouTube,
como Facebook o Twitter están obligados a
retirar el contenido “dañino” en menos
de 24 horas de la notificación de las autoridades.
Si no lo hacen, pueden tener que pagar multas
de hasta 50 millones de euros.
¿El problema? El problema es que, lo que
en principio podría ser una ley para evitar
la propaganda terrorista, terminó convirtiéndose
en algo mucho peor.
Semanas después de que se aprobara esta ley,
tanto Twitter como Facebook le quitaron la
cuenta a una diputada de Alternativa por Alemania
por lanzar mensajes contra los inmigrantes.
Pero es que, días después, Twitter también
eliminó la cuenta de la… revista satírica
que había mencionado a esa política para
reírse de ella. Y unos días más tarde,
Twitter también le cerró la cuenta a una
humorista que hizo otro chiste sobre Alternativa
por Alemania. Conclusión, si tienes Twitter
en Alemania… ¡Mejor no hables de inmigrantes!
Ni a favor ni en contra.
¡Y no creáis que hablamos de sólo un par
de casos extremos! Para que os hagáis una
idea, sólo en los 6 primeros meses de 2019,
YouTube tuvo que borrar más de 280 vídeos.
Y vaya por delante que YouTube es la única
empresa que ha hecho público. Pero de las
diferencias entre Facebook, Twitter y YouTube
a la hora de moderar el contenido hablaremos
en otro vídeo que sacaremos pronto. Si no
os lo queréis perder, ya sabéis, suscribíos
a este canal y dadle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Lo cierto es que esta ley alemana ha creado
escuela. En 2020 Francia sacó otra ley para
luchar contra el discurso de odio. La diferencia
es que, en este caso, el Tribunal Constitucional
consiguió tumbarla.
Y aquí es donde entra el otro gran problema
con las legislaciones que quieren regular
las fake news, la desinformación y el discurso
de odio. La mayor parte de los países democráticos
tienen constituciones que reconocen la libertad
de expresión. Por supuesto, todas ellas reconocen
ciertas excepciones como el derecho al honor.
Pero, en este caso, estamos hablando de algo
mucho más profundo. Hablamos de poder censurar
contenido por motivos… difíciles de definir.
Sin embargo, dentro de la Unión Europea hay
cada vez más voces que piden políticas reales
para frenar
el “contenido dañino”. Y por eso, en
primavera de 2021, la Comisión Europea ha
publicado el…
“ESTUDIO DE LA RESPONSABILIDAD DE LAS PLATAFORMAS
ONLINE”
¡Habéis oído bien! La doctrina está clara:
las plataformas online son responsables por
el contenido que tienen. No sólo deben actuar
cuando hay una violación de copyright sino
también cuando hay una violación de la decencia
y moral pública. Así que este estudio propone
4 escenarios distintos: a) no hacer nada,
b) hacer campañas de educación mediática
entre la población… (¡Es lo que dice!)
c) regulación público privada y d) auto
regulación.
¡Habéis oído bien! Por el momento, el escenario
que más se baraja en Europa es que las propias
plataformas se autorregulen. Es decir, que
creen una serie de normas y se encarguen ellas
solas de borrar todo el contenido malicioso
que se haya podido colar. Y diréis… ¡Bueno!
¿Dónde está el problema entonces? Pues
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
LOS ORÍGENES DEL FINAL FELIZ
¿Y si os dijera que el final feliz tan típico
de Hollywood nació como respuesta a la censura?
¡Habéis oído bien! El final feliz nació
en una época donde las películas no podían
terminar mal. No, al menos, si querían recibir
el sello de aprobación para poderse proyectar
en salas de cine. Os voy a dar un ejemplo:
“Mister Smith Goes to Washintgon” es una
película de Frank Capra. Esta película cuenta
la historia de un político idealista que
se tiene que enfrentar a todos los senadores
corruptos de Washington. En principio, no
parece que tenga que ser ningún tema censurable
¿Verdad? ¡Recordad que esta película es
del año 1939! Criticar el funcionamiento
del sistema americano podía verse como…
¿¡PROPAGANDA COMUNISTA!? En aquel momento,
las películas tenían que transmitir valores
morales. Eso significa que los malos tenían
que ser castigados, el bueno tenía que ganar
y la moraleja de la historia debía ser “moral”
¡Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos!
¿Cómo es posible? Si algo caracteriza a
Estados Unidos es la libertad de expresión.
Está bien clarita en la primera enmienda
de la Constitución. Y sí tenéis razón
¿El problema? El problema es viene cuando
consideras que el cine NO es un medio de expresión
¡Ya lo sé! Pensaréis que me he vuelto loco.
Pero eso es exactamente lo que ocurrió. No
olvidéis una cosa: estamos hablando de principios
del siglo 20. Por aquel entonces, el cine
era una nueva tecnología, tal y como ahora
pueden ser las plataformas de contenido en
internet.
Y precisamente esa fue la doctrina judicial
que dictó la Corte Suprema de Estados Unidos
en 1915. Atentos al veredicto final.
La exibición de películas es un negocio,
simple y llanamente (…) y no se puede considerar
como parte de la prensa del país o como un
órgano de opinión pública dentro de los
parámetros de la libertad de expresión
—Mutual Film Corporation vs Industrial Commission
of Ohio, 1915
Sí, habéis oído bien. El cine no se consideraba
un medio de expresión ¡Pero esperad un momento
porque la historia no termina aquí! ¿Habéis
oído hablado del #MeToo? ¡Pues tampoco es
algo nuevo! El Harvey Weinstein de 1920 era
un actor de comedia: ROSCOE “FATTY” ARBUCKLE.
El escándalo Fatty era la historia escabrosa
perfecta: sexo, asesinatos y estrellas de
Hollywood. El cocktail perfecto para vender
periódicos ¿Y a que no adivináis quién
fue el magnate de los medios que más réditos
sacó de esta historia? ¡Exacto! William
Randolph Hearst. Por aquel entonces, ya tenía
varios periódicos en todo el país. De un
día para otro, los escándalos sexuales de
Hollywood se convirtieron en el tema de conversación
de todos los bares y peluquerías de Estados
Unidos. Todo el país estaba escandalizado
con la falta de moral de las estrellas. Y
en mitad de este pánico moral, los estados
decidieron empezar a legislar. Como el cine
ya no se consideraba un medio de comunicación,
los distintos estados de Estados Unidos pudieron
aprobar toda clase de leyes de censura. Para
el año 1921, ya había 37 estados con censura.
Y en ese momento es cuando Hollywood decidió
actuar. Así “Motions Pictures Association
of America” (((PRONUNCIAR ESTO CON UN ACENTO
MUY AMERICANO))) creó un código de buenas
prácticas ¿Os suena de algo esta historia?
Y os preguntaréis ¿Pero cómo se crea un
código de buenas prácticas morales? Pues
muy fácil ¿Quiénes eran los mayores expertos
en moral pública en aquel momento? ¡Pues
obviamente! ¡LOS CURAS! Así es como Hollywood
contrató a este señor que veis en pantalla:
WILLIAM HARRISON HAYS: un sacerdote presbiteriano
¡Y no creáis que repararon en gastos! El
señor Hays llegó a cobrar un sueldo de 100.000
dólares al año de la época. En dólares
de hoy en día, estaríamos hablando de más
de 1,5 millones de dólares al año. Además,
este hombre contrató a un equipo de sacerdotes
para que le ayudaran a crear el código. Un
código que se tardó años en terminar y
que, desde entonces, se conoce como el “código
Hays”. Un código de censura con normas
tan detalladas como esta:
“Los personajes de sacerdotes no podrán
ser utilizados como personajes cómicos o
villanos”
—Extracto del Código de Producción de
Películas
Desde el año 1934, todas las películas tenían
que pasar por un tribunal de curas para que
le pusieran el sello moral. Y fijaos bien
en un detalle: hablamos de algo mucho peor
que censura. La censura de Hollywood no se
limitaba a eliminar una escena concreta o
a prohibir tal o cual cosa. Al ser algo aceptado
por las propias productoras, la censura afectaba
a toda la historia.
Por ejemplo ¿Habéis visto “El Halcón
Maltés”? Si leéis el libro en el que está
basado, veréis que hay un personaje abiertamente
homosexual. Recordad que la literatura SÍ
estaba considerada como un medio de comunicación.
Así que las novelas sí disfrutaban de libertad
de expresión. Sin embargo, en la película,
ese mismo personaje no podía ser ni abiertamente
homosexual ni bueno. Así que terminó siendo
un señor simplemente afeminado y, por supuesto,
el malo de la película. Desde los años 30
hasta los 60, podréis encontrar cientos de
ejemplos como este. Por suerte, en los años
60, la Corte Suprema cambió su doctrina.
Hoy en día, el cine en Estados Unidos disfruta
de la misma libertad de expresión que cualquier
otro medio de comunicación.
Sin embargo, parece que la misma historia
se repite con otra nueva tecnología.
La Comisión Europea y las empresas tecnológicas
anuncian un código de conducta contra el
discurso de odio ilegal
Comisión Europea 31-05-2016
¡Habéis oído bien! Pero, antes de que os
echéis las manos a la cabeza, dejadme que
os diga que, por el momento, este código
es bastante amplio. Es decir, por el momento,
los únicos límites marcados son para evitar
propaganda de grupos terroristas, mensajes
de odio claros que ya estaban prohibidos en
casi todos los países ¿El problema? El problema
es que este código es del año 2016. Ahora
estamos en 2021 y Europa pide aún más restricciones.
Guías para reforzar el Código de prácticas
en materia de desinformación
Comisión Europea 25-05-2021
El gran problema que Europa quiere solucionar
ya no es el discurso de odio sino la desinformación.
Es decir, las fake news y las teorías de
la conspiración que han crecido como la espuma
en época del Coronavirus. El problema es
¿Quién dice lo que es verdad y no? ¿De
verdad se puede juzgar esto sin estar libre
de sesgos? ¿Y cómo pueden autorregularse
las plataformas de internet? De eso hablaremos
la próxima semana aquí, en VisualPolitik.
Y vamos a ver con todo lujo de detalles las
diferencias entre estos tres personajes:
la CEO de YouTube, el CEO de Facebook y el
CEO de Twitter. Pero mientras tanto, podéis
dejarme vuestra opinión en los comentarios
¿Cómo creéis que se pueden filtrar las
fake news en internet? ¿De verdad debemos
hacerlo? Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta
en los comentarios. Mientras tanto, no olvidéis
que aquí, en VisualPolitik, sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
a este canal y dadle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo. Un saludo y hasta
pronto.